when did you guys wrap on cherry and how
is the post-production process been so
we wrapped at the beginning of February
where you know we're very diligent about
getting into the Edit room every night
after we shoot while we're shooting we
do that for two reasons one is we want
to process what we've been shooting and
make sure that we honor you know that we
like the tone we like the direction of
character is moving in but also are we
missing any story beats which is
critically important that before you rap
you know you can rewrite or reshoot or
you know add a day or two at the end to
get a few essential pieces that you
think are gonna help the story and we
certainly did that on cherry so we were
very advanced in the cut by the time we
finished the movie then you know
pre-pandemic we're able to get a lot of
work done in the Edit room and so we're
pretty close to lacking picture by the
time we all had to sequester and I think
you know we spent some time with our
editor honest relaying keys at his house
with the avid and we can watch it on the
screen and give them notes but we're
pretty close on it and we're gonna start
sound spotting and and music spotting
next week and get into the score and
sound design and you know the movie be
ready by the end of the summer question
is you know what what is what's the
market look like moving forward when can
people go back to a movie theater and
will they be able to go back to a movie
theater for a year or two we don't know
obviously I saw some pictures of Tom
Holland and you've released some images
when before you make a movie you
obviously hope for everything that's
going to happen a certain way and you
envisioned it I would imagine be
combined what surprised you about Tom's
performance that maybe you weren't
expecting
I think he's exceptional in the movie
honest I think it's as an oscar-worthy
performance out of him he is shredding
himself physically and emotionally and
this is a movie that spans decades and
you know he is really playing a very
complicated individual who is both a
drug addict and suffering from PTSD and
a bank robber and you know in a failing
relationship and it's a very complicated
and and I just thought I just think he's
exquisite in the part and he's so
compulsively watchable on screen and
when you're playing a character that
goes to that level of depravity to have
someone as inherently likable as Tom
playing that character so that you
continue to root for them no matter what
horrible choices they may make is just
it's it's invaluable and I think it it
really it really changes the entire
presentation of the movie for an
audience so I you know I can't say
enough about it and I'm just blown away
by him in the film you obviously
Wheatland I'm curious what but was it
really like going back there and making
such a personal story I know you and
aunt very personal story - the - um what
was it like filming it was amazing I
mean it's the atmosphere the third movie
we've done in Cleveland so we love our
hometown
we have emotional connection to a lot of
locations in the film Nikko Walker wrote
the book grew up in the same area
Cleveland that we grew up in it was a
few years behind us his life took a
completely different turn than our lives
took and you know you know we worked at
the same restaurant that I worked at
just years behind me so it was our
childhood unfolding in the movie and we
shot at a lot of locations that held
them like I said you know real emotional
resonance for us and so rarely do you
get to do that with the movie with this
kind of story so it was um it was I
think career-defining for us